Nhà cửa đầu sắp bốc trảy cầu đường đức gái, hàng luận công chính hư hại nặng nay sơ chật đất tại Nhật Banh.
Chật đất mạnh mây về một lộ xe ra châu hai mình tạm tháng bài, tâm chánh ở độ sau khoảng 1km, thành phố OK,
khiến nhiều khu vực thuộc tình của mà một tổ dùng là sử dội.
Tại Thị chánh Casima, cách tâm chánh khoảng 2km, chúng tâm thương mại Aion Môn Fatnổ sau độ đất khiến tòa nhạy hư hại.
Theo NHK, lực lượng cứ hộ dại cứu được tạm người trong đó năm 2019 và tìm thấy 2 người thiệt mạng trong đổ nổ nát.
Cảnh sẽ cho biết khoảng 2 chăm khách hàng và nhân viên đã được sơ tán trước khi buộc lồ sẻ ra, công tắc tìm kiếm cứu hộ vẫn đang được chiến khai.
Tại thành phố ER Suciro, kích tâm trấn khoảng 14 kí lồ mét, hộ đống khỏi lớn trong nhà máy độ sắp vui lấp nhiều cơm nhân, lực lượng cứu hộ sách nhận 2 người trong tình trạng lần tiêm vội chiến người vẫn mất tích.
Đen ER Suciro trong khu zi tích thành cộ ER Suciro, cùng nhiều cuộc đen đã cũng bị đồ sắp sông trận đất.
Saan hai chính thân bây, thủ tướng nhất bạn tả kai chỉ xa này, cho biết là trận đất đã khiến người bán người thiệt mạng.
Chính quyền tình của mà một tô khi nhận bán người tử vong năm người trong tình trạng lần tiêm vui và bà miếm bốt người bị thường.
Theo thủ tình sả Việt Nam đã sự quan Việt Nam tại nhất bán cho biết một loạt động Việt Nam thiệt mạng và ít nhất một người khác bị thường.